Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Muriel de Meo
Condivisione:
condivisione, all'interno della musica,
come elemento imprescindibile
dell'improvvisazione.
E l'improvvisazione
come elemento importantissimo,
all'interno della musica Jazz.
Nella storia della musica Jazz,
uno dei più grandi esecutori,
e improvvisatori,
che ha suonato questo strumento
si chiamava Lionel Hampton.
E a lui, e agli amici di Parigi,
dedico questo brano.
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Nella seconda parte, proviamo a fare
una condivisione al contrario.
Cioè, non pretendo che tutti voi
veniate qua a suonare;
però, anziché essere io
a dare vibrazioni a voi,
sarete voi a darle a me.
Proviamo a fare un esperimento,
in cinque minuti.
Un improvvisazione, insomma,
a seconda di quello che arriva qua.
Vibrate bene perché sennò sbaglio, eh!
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie.